[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record we're talking about
whatever we want it's tight do it again
hey guys welcome back to all three where
we talk about whatever we
want oh i love that you can hear it
right
i like that i hope they can anyway tim
is here with the mask on and he's
shocked for some reason and he's taking
his mask off and he just threw it on his
table and now he's
crossing just gonna narrate the video
for all the uh you know the people who
can't see them
that's exactly right oh his brother
likes to watch
uh tv shows with that the the audio
helps things the description shot
really every time we log on to his
account because he has a cbs
we watch we watch twilight zone twilight
zone and every single episode because
he's already watched him
and like like the settings are saved or
whatever every single episode has
the the and he can see narration yeah
he's fine yeah wait what are you talking
like subtitles
no so there's like the for blind people
yeah
there's this option just like for deaf
people there's subtitles right but then
for blind people there's the audio
descript
descriptives yeah oh i didn't even know
that was if you were watching jk
yeah if i was to like throw this hat it
would be like tim throws his hat into
the air yeah yeah and catches it
oh but it's like a quieter kind of
background voice almost
it's very annoying so it describes
everything that's happening yeah
does the action scene sound like left
punch right punch kick kick kick
yeah it's thrown over the building i'm
not sure i don't know
i turn it off or is it more like pow pow
poo poo poo pam
it's more descriptive oh way more
descriptive yeah because um
like in the beginning so like i said
like it starts in the beginning of every
episode we have to pause it and then
like turn it off and then restart it but
in those like
first few seconds it's like um image
showing a white male with his eye
blinking or
whatever it is but like it's giving more
description than what
i'm seeing so i didn't even know that it
was a man's eyeball because
like she ends up telling me or it's like
you're okay
i was gonna say no it's like you're
reading a screenplay of it oh yeah yeah
the action line did you ever ask your
brother why he does that
no actually i don't even know if it's
maybe it's just like it's a
a [ __ ] glitch oh he does go over to
his house
uh he'll have it on and he'll like turn
it off for us why don't you guys break
his balls and ask him what's going on
i need to know why i asked him yes or
maybe maybe he watches tv like this
relaxation time my old man maybe he's
trying to force the feature i call it
forcing a feature my old man bought
a tv back in the day rear projection
like 50 inch screen when those were like
like two years out right there as
expensive as [ __ ]
and it has the picture and picture
option pip
so you can have like a little window
come up and you can move it around if
you want to wherever you want
and so he tried to make that work for a
while and eventually we're all just like
hey dad like this sucks we don't want it
and he's like yeah it does suck huh yeah
what was he playing in the little one it
was a football game and then another
football game
oh wow so you can keep track of two
scores you can't even see it though you
can't see [ __ ] it's pointless
but you know what sometimes i like to
have things on in the background when i
do stuff
saying he likes to just listen to a
movie
yeah maybe you're like cooking or
something you don't have time to look up
all the times you just just tell me
everything
huh brother you're talking about his
brother yes yes yes yes
because it tells you out loud right yeah
yeah because like you ever watch
something but you have to get up and
check something or whatever you don't
want to pause it
but you don't want to just listen
because you're going to miss so maybe
that's the thing it's like because i
need to know what happened isn't it
distract from the actual
dialogue or the it depends on guess what
you're looking for see i don't need this
because i have a wife right so if i get
up
and i'm in the kitchen she's like oh
yeah well he just got on one knee i
think he's going to ask her to be his
girlfriend and i'm like
i can hear it though
have you guys seen that meme where it's
like kids today will never know what
it's like
having a sibling to help you like when
commercials over and it's like it's back
on
because you have to go run and go pee
yeah that's true there's no live tv
yeah yeah they get deposit they have the
privilege of paul i know dude
everyone or no commercials they're so
special
netflix i didn't have a sibling so i
would just count and i knew like the
commercial's roughly like 30 seconds
i would run it go take shot one two
three four shower
eight nine ten and i'm like twenty seven
eight three nine three i run back and
i'm like
oh okay you can't take no shot no i'm
serious
like at your friend's house at a
sleepover or whatever and then you gotta
go
pee or whatever yeah and they're like
it's on
yeah exactly that's how you know how
long do they give you to take a [ __ ] in
the military
uh like in boot camp yeah oh man it's
like
really there's no like specific
time but it's not like how long you get
it's there's like let's say
80 recruits and there's only 10 toilets
and the guy's counting down at 59.85
before so you guys figure it out
so usually what happens is there's a guy
taking a [ __ ] with his legs open another
guy peeing through here
what because he needs to piss too wait
question wait wait we didn't explain
who's counting the drill instructor so
they do give you a certain time
so he's just like ready go so i think
legally it's supposed to be like a
minute like there's like
laws that america says like amount of
time for all y'all to
be done in the bathroom like kind of
like how like you know there's union
times right but then in the military
they always take those rules and they
bend it like a [ __ ]
so like okay cool you got 60 seconds so
they they're 60 seconds it's
60 90 70 so it's not even mississippi so
it's probably like really 20 or 30
seconds
i kind of like that though because i
don't want our soldiers in war going
time's out time's out i gotta poop i
gotta poop well dude they did that
during world war two like times that
time's out it's christmas
and then they had to work did you hear
about that no yeah and then like they
kind of had like a little bit of a
christmas thing
and they had their homemade with their
arms blown off so merry christmas dude
he's just like
it was one of the it was one of the
world wars don't quote me there's a
famous moment where like they all just
had christmas and then they killed each
other the next day kind of like what
it's a war too it would be even crazier
if they were celebrating together
no they were no they were i'm not
kidding no way
let me see christmas truce yeah look it
up it was like a christmas
truce thing yeah so like allies and axe
these powers were just i don't know if
it was world war one or two just don't
quote him on which war it was he said
i didn't need to know which war it was
sorry wait so was it the
world war we definitely didn't do it in
iraq and afghanistan so 1776
revolution that's right
all right so it's called the christmas
truce yeah see or
wine nice friday so it's german
so it was a widespread unofficial
ceasefire
along the western front of the first
world war
soldiers from both sides the british and
the germans
exchanged cheerful conversation wow
yeah that's cool how do you even
organize that yeah
we can't organize our own congress we
can't just like tweet it out
it's kind of like you ever been in those
situations where there's a picture of
them hanging out
that's tight oh let me air drop into the
computer
i know a couple things it's kind of
similar to you ever had two groups of
people that didn't like each other
and after [ __ ] arguing and [ __ ]
you're like okay okay here's what we're
gonna do uh
we're gonna you you fight one person
from your group fight one person from
our group and you kind of come this
little understanding and it's like
that's what's gonna happen and
afterwards you're like all right well
[ __ ] that's what happened
dab it up it's done i'm gonna take it
outside that's tight i couldn't
drop it to the big computer and that
wild man it's just [ __ ] interesting
yeah look at that they're all friends
and like merry christmas to you merry
christmas to you
and they even had a baby christmas treat
that's insane and then the very next day
they're back to
destroying each other they're all smiles
and [ __ ] it's christmas
[ __ ] tiff yeah but like it's perfect
it's
weird i know it's like hey you know
earlier when he threw that grenade at me
that's why
it's cool for now yeah and then the neck
is like i'm gonna kill you tomorrow
it's like all right 1201
all right man he's like and then he's
like oh i just stabbed through the candy
cane it shattered
i gotta go one time they were sucking it
to make them oh oh
that's like christmas shanks he's like
i'm still in christmas mode
damn that's so crazy during that time
too they should be
social distancing because they had a
worse pandemic than we did spanish flu
was it
during the world war ones that was
during world war one
a lot of [ __ ] going on back then more
people died from that pandemics
than the actual war damn the soldiers
died more from the sickness
do quality life was so bad back then
though you die and you're like thank you
[Laughter]
yes yeah well it's all like perspective
right
relative to that time so then for us a
lot of people in our time are probably
feeling like that if those guys were
still alive though they'd be telling us
like
back in my day yeah i know right yo back
in my day you get diarrhea you're a dead
man
there's nothing back in my day you catch
the spanish flu and you die within an
hour
that's some crazy [ __ ] really crazy
mm-hmm
only but you so we we've got focused on
the time of the shits and the pisses but
you said
you spread your legs as you're taking a
[ __ ] while someone else is pissing
between your legs yeah why are you sp
there's you don't have time to wait so
so the first so the first i registered
spreading cheeks and that's why i said
why
oh it's in the [ __ ] the first thing
is uh
there's a time limit right and then so
that's like the first
restriction the second thing is there's
way more people than there are
facilities
so there's that the third thing is we're
all a team
so we know how much it sucks if i need
to pee
or poo and then this time is up and now
i have to hold it for the next four
hours until that happens so everyone is
trying to hook each other up
so if there's two guys to a urinal and i
see someone going like this
i'm like scooting this [ __ ] over
and i go like this
so we can all get each other's backs and
like it's just all [ __ ] pissed here
like right now that sounds like some
turbulent times but
like i'm gonna tell you something right
now real quick that upstart
is sponsoring this video during these
economically
turbulent times wow everyone is looking
for a way to feel
more financially secure so if you're
still needlessly throwing money
every month at high interest credit card
debt it's time you checked out upstart
baby
the revolutionary online lending
platform that
knows you're more than just a credit
score now is the time to find out how
low your upstart rate can be to help pay
off high
interest credit card debt how low
extremely low
you got to find out but unlike other
lenders upstart can reward you
based on your education and job history
in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or diploma to
apply though yep so upstart lets you
skip going to the big because it's
completely online they offer loans from
a thousand
to get this fifty thousand
dollars 50 000 yup so you can
consolidate your debt into one easy fix
fixed rate payment baby upstart makes it
fast and simple to check your rate
since it's just a soft pull it won't
affect your credit score the hard pull
happens when if you accept your rate and
proceed with your application and the
best part if the loan is approved and
accepted
most people get their funds the very
next business day
wow over 400 000 people have used
upstart to pay off credit cards or meet
their financial goals so free yourself
from the burden of high interest credit
card debt and get back to using your
money
your way with upstart see why upstart
has a 4.9 out of 5
rating on trustpilot and hurry up to
upstart.com
record to find out how low your upstart
rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
record um i peed in between chia's legs
when she was peeing one time
you've told me about this you you
doubled it but those guys had five
extra toilets this was um after a new
year's drunken night we're staying in a
hotel in l.a because you know we knew
we're going to be drunk and [ __ ]
so i was like responsible yeah and i was
like i really
and i had joked about like i really
wanted to do it because i thought it was
funny
and and then as soon as we got back to
the hotel and she had to pee i was like
okay i'm gonna do it
so she sat down and peed and then i peed
like just in between that little like
you know just spot and uh
it was really funny did she open her
legs or like did you pee behind her
no no no front words yeah yeah did you
try to cross dreams with her
i probably did [ __ ] funny camp can
you have
personal time like you know when you
when everyone goes back to sleepy time
and you just like yeah i gotta rub one
out or i gotta go kaka like is it like
that there's
uh so you don't have personal time um
for
at least the first month so you pee when
they tell you you poop when they tell
you
you eat when they tell you pretty much
yeah like the first year what happens if
there's an emergency you just do it then
[ __ ] on yourself what's considered
emergency like like uh
pee or poop like what if you're in the
middle of a drill and you have
you just you just should appear on
yourself like nothing is more important
than
what your personal needs are but by the
way bart's talking about the marines
right now if you're in the air force
like they'll bring a porta potty to you
yeah and they give you like two
and they give you they give you apple no
this is real yeah exactly
i love ripping it on the [ __ ] noises
i love rivet on the air force because my
whole family's air force so it's very
fun
and my grandpa was a marine so he like
does he's one of them real hard on about
that [ __ ] yeah the jokes being
geared towards army people oh yeah army
people are around army people are a
different
different breed i never hear people
making fun of marines though what's the
marine jokes
nobody makes fun of marines yeah i
thought they were like the top they're
the hardest one i guess in normal
branches it's the hardest ones and all
sort of i guess they call them jar heads
because they're like they they call them
dumb sometimes i guess
like does that yeah does that but
everyone makes fun of navy by the way
too
but air force is probably the best one
to make fun of how about green berets
they're armies they're like special ops
guys no one really [ __ ] with those guys
and the navy seals like making fun of
they really wear green berets they
really do
and nobody really knows about space
force yet so we don't know what the joke
is yet right my porta-potty's
floating around isn't it
wait so the first month you go in and
then they're like
there's no teacher i gotta go to the
bathroom it's like you [ __ ] [ __ ] on
yourself
yeah so you go this recruit like you run
up and you know this recruit request
permission to use the head or whatever
and if he denies you oh how do you learn
that
verbiage the head they tell you everyone
knows the head i don't know what it is
third four uh third person you go this
recruit requests permission
to use the head they tell you right off
the bat like if you use restroom that's
what you say
i thought i turned it off i'm sorry it's
my fault
oh i thought it just turned off sir
permission to
boo boo yeah pretty much and then if he
goes get the [ __ ] out of my face and you
go okay i'm gonna go [ __ ] myself
did you [ __ ] yourself you just [ __ ] your
stuff is it co it was was it co-ed
by the time you got in because gi jane
was like old right so then like
by the time you got in there's women
right no i think bootcamp is still
separate i'm not sure though
yeah i'm still not i'm not sure she was
so [ __ ] fine in that movie was
pretty sick oh the shade
she looks so good with the shade insane
yeah i've never seen the movie but i've
seen photos and yes i agree yeah
it's wild so if is do you know if they
do boot camp
gender like like it's different and then
afterwards they bring them together or
yeah so in boot camp i don't know if
it's
co-ed just yet but back then it wasn't
oh
well there wasn't female is females in
combat allowed
until like just a couple years ago i
think yeah that's really recent so you
mean they were allowed in the military
but they weren't infantry
yeah they're like other jobs you could
be like um i don't like a medic a nurse
or whatever there's other jobs
you serve but you just weren't in combat
can't be in the front lines
oh wow i didn't know that until just a
couple years ago i think yeah
yeah how do you guys feel about the
co-ed bathrooms like
like so we were just talking about this
earlier where the first time i had
ever witnessed a co-ed bathroom was that
youtube space and it was actually for
your roast
yeah at that so that restroom that they
had it was just like one gigantic room
and then there's stalls
oh yeah but there's men and women using
it and that was the first time ever my
whole life i had ever
been in a restroom where there's guys
around i'm like this is weird
okay so that that never tripped me out
because it's all stalls right yeah and
so you don't really you only see people
when you're washing your hands but when
i went to a beautycon
in new york uh what can you take a [ __ ]
well here's the thing right it was
it was it was a co-ed bathroom and it
was stalls and it was urinals
oh [ __ ] yeah so i'm like so in my head
i'm walking her i walk into the bathroom
i'm like okay
cool there's women in line men and women
in line to get into the bathroom but of
course the women are lying for the
stalls
and so i'm like in my head i'm like oh
it's kind of hot i'm gonna have my dick
out because girls around but then like
i'm standing at the urinal and i cannot
pee i'm like so
nervous like the shy yeah i'm like i'm
sitting there
and i'm standing there forever just
waiting like you know i'm just like
okay just waiting for my p to come out
and one girl was like
taking a while there so
good like i'm i'm like i'm trying to
relax she's like
though cute like in your imagination
it's like
that's like the hardest situation you
could think yeah because like oh [ __ ]
yeah well it's it's kind of hot cause
like something's in there like oh your
penis is out there's strange women
around it's kind of hot
so in that moment when you're holding
your dick and you're peeing
so like this is it right like sure you
hold it like this from the base or do
you hold it like closer to like
the tip to kind of cover it like a
garden hose yeah you more like a garden
hose
closer to the base so you have control
with the thumb pressing it so it turns
the shape of the stream differently
that i thought you were green well
that's how we get it all over the seat
you guys always wanted to know the
secret that women don't know is that we
do put the thumb in front
just [ __ ] i knew it no because then
like if you're embarrassed and you're
like near
other people i would imagine you'd want
to cover most of it no it was no it
wasn't like so let me here's the setup
okay
um let's say i'm facing let's say this
is the urinal
and i'm facing the urinal this is out of
the way okay let's say i'm facing the
urinal here
and then i'm here trying to pee here's
the line of women going this way towards
the stalls
so i'm here here's the door so it's like
they're coming this way
and i'm so i'm like chilling right here
and i there's women just in line for the
for the stalls and so it's no one's like
over my shoulder
possibly seeing my dick at all but it's
just it's still kind of like yeah
man you know sure but what if you got a
fart
because like i feel more comfortable
around guys because we get it's like oh
yeah let's
[ __ ] just let it all out right maybe
women too right like you go in you
just like i'm gonna take a [ __ ] right
now and just let it out right but do you
feel more
self-conscious now because it's like oh
there's other people here now thank god
i didn't have to ship i think maine
most normal people do but i think you
would be fine
i know i'm worried that's why i ask
because i'm gonna do it regardless
yeah you're right about that but it i'm
also worried
you know like i don't have to worry if
you go to any of those like big events
like a concert or whatever technically
it's co-ed because it's just a row of
porta-potties
guys girls whatever so it's just to me
it's like we've already been doing it
for
decades but it's called the portal potty
so we're
going through the portal you're going to
keep going
it's one of the rings of hell as well
i love it because uh girls are much
cleaner than guys so it's just like
it'll be twenty percent cleaner maybe
yeah and then we have to put up with
your [ __ ] piss all over the seat
oh wow i know right i feel just bad for
the girls you have to deal with those
guys make us all look bad though cause i
don't do the piss on the sides
so it's one guy out there and he's
looking up pooping on the toilet scene
oh that's the worst when you find that
how much on that
i blame children because even in the
girls restrooms there's [ __ ] on the
seats
and i'm like that's a kid and the mom is
not cleaning it he's not cleaning it
dude i heard tiger [ __ ] the pool the
other day
sometimes there's poop on the wall of
the stall
does he stay in the pool often no this
is his first time so we're in the pool
like hanging out
and then uh he starts going so he knows
like if he needs to poo he needs to tell
us especially he doesn't have his
diapers
his diaper on so he starts going
and then we're like wait what what
that's the alarm yeah and then we're
like
oh [ __ ] he's in the water so uh i think
uh geo saw like
of a little brown cloud oh no so she
picks him up
and puts him on the on the ledge and he
just starts
going to town and all the water diapers
sometimes we just have him naked
and he just starts [ __ ] and it just
starts he just started coming out on the
ledge and he felt so bad like
because he broke a roux well he started
crying like
he betrayed the family yeah because he
was embarrassed because
someone other than his parents was there
too could be i don't know i don't know
if it was like or maybe all of our
reaction like oh my god the pool
oh the energy we never applied that kind
of shame to him
like he usually has no shame like just
have fun and it could be everyone going
oh
and maybe as a little kid like seeing
like three adults going
like oh yeah it's a huge deal you know i
mean he's he's he's not dumb he
understands like this is something
he's like ah [ __ ] the pool you know yeah
he's lucky that you're his dad though
because my grandpa would have called me
a bullshitter for 10 years
what do you do to your pool when that
happens when they're [ __ ] there was
just one nugget
and then so you just kind of threw it
away yeah i just scooped it with the
bucket
threw it out and then there was i
scooped it yeah just scooped it with the
bucket threw it out and then there was a
little yellow cloud and i kind of like
scooped it from underneath the water
and i went like that on the lawn and i
just rinsed off his ass
pool party at barts with that kind of
precision pool cleaning
you can count on a quality experience
bart is a pool cleaner he's like with
his hands
he doesn't use it he's got his [ __ ]
hands out with his fingers spread and he
picks the pool up and puts it under a
rug
don't worry guys i got it i put the
piece of paper it's divided from the
rest of this water
and then and then and then bart's taking
he's taking water from bottles and he's
like
refilling it yeah refilling we're good
guys yeah he's like that's really clean
water he's drinking from it
you